i'm literally wet with anticipation
the edited version of our talent
extravaganza is now available
online with guest videos
live performances she's getting digged
down in dallas
that's
sketches i didn't get no tests
she's dead and mas mas mas
slim and biscuit you are heavenly
you guys have each other he is [__]
cute open your mouth
boom there you go if you missed it then
um you can unmiss it and if you
already watched it you sucked you can
re-watch this
uh revised version with updated audio
and video
that kid ain't [__] and thank you for
your support and we'll see you guys
we'll see you more we'll continue to see
you
goodbye i'll whoop in your ass after the
show
kade uh look